congratulations on season three very
exciting thank you
welcome you're welcome so listen Lucian
I heard that you all have a group chat
on WhatsApp okay the thing uh you're
making me nervous now I'm nervous now
I'm nervous I'm nervous wait wait don't
be nervous don't be nervous do you think
they know group chat and I want to know
who takes the longest to answer in the
group chat
yeah it's definitely made it's 110 me
I'm the worst person at texting in
general let alone in a group chat and
then I get so overwhelmed when I see
everyone's messages but um then I'll
just call someone I'm like Ashley where
do we need to be William what we doing
just break it down for me just give me
just just give it to me real quick he
also have four different phone numbers
right there's so many listen group chat
is overwhelming I'm that person too so I
don't blame you Lucy and it's okay
I saw you described being on the show as
like a real pinch me moment can you
explain why this is such like a a moment
of like living in a dream
well as um
our friend George Clooney famously said
I think he's the one who said that he
said I you know the the job of it what's
hard about being an actor is not the
labor of it it's getting the job
so I've been doing this for a minute and
a half and and I've worked thank God you
know fairly consistently but landing a
job like this is you know changes the
Dynamics a little bit and it's uh uh you
know it's it feels it felt like a reward
to all those years trying to make that
happen to land that that job and so for
that I'm grateful every day and uh uh
you know I I pinch myself because it's a
you know it's a one in a hundred uh
you know and I'm you know I'm two years
older than he is so my perspective on
the whole thing is different uh so I'm
uh you know I'm very very uh very very
grateful it's it's a real it's a dream
I'm living the dream and I'm back you
know I live in the states I'm back here
in Paris I used to live here it's so
confusing so it makes it even more
dreamy
right do you have a favorite do you have
a favorite spot in Paris like are you
showing them around are you like showing
dishes you need to eat I I'm trying to
bring everybody to the Luxembourg garden
they're sick of it uh okay it's a
beautiful garden on the Left Bank and it
has all my little you know uh uh Hobbies
there you know you can run you can play
tennis you can just wander around you
can sit on the chair you can romance
beautiful Fontana disease you can play
tennis you're like that there's kids you
know there's kids running around from
the school if they're such a nice
youthful beautiful energy in that place
it's uh I love it amazing okay while I'm
adding it to my list so thank you I
appreciate that now Lucian I have to ask
I would be remiss not to ask who do you
think Emily should end up with Alfie or
Gabriel you know something who knows
what tomorrow has she's gonna live in
the present I think and roll the punches
and roll with the UPS to Downs the the
highs the lows of it all and I think for
right now I think I think Alfie's that
that that playmaker for now
maybe not later who knows who knows but
um but yeah I think just just living in
the moment a little bit and don't you
don't have to figure have love figured
out I don't think too much so I think uh
I think yeah as long as you're truthful
to yourself at the moment then yeah
it's good advice that's good advice I
hope everyone's listening yeah okay was
that good advice can all right can I
write that down I blacked out for a
second I don't know what I just said
I promise all right so what's the vibe
like with the cast off camera I mean you
become kind of like a bit of a family
right like what do you all like to do
for fun are you going to the club are we
partying what are we doing listen we're
doing a mixture of everything like I say
William will have everyone down to look
some good Gardens playing tennis we'll
be chilling we'll be we'll be spitting
some of the lines together going through
the scripts and stuff like that
um we over at Wilson's house cooking up
some food it's it's something that um is
something that really really is special
about this job here and for me being
kind of I guess still the Newbie to the
team it's um it's and starting something
in within Cove the covert time I think
there's a before cover time and after
cover time I think yeah I'm starting
something in curve it brought us all
together so much
um that our Bond's pretty we're pretty
tight yeah we like to talk about on some
times to collect your eyes yeah yeah
that's awesome that's like wait who's
the last person to leave the club just
this one the last person to leave oh we
shouldn't we're all shooting that down
together we mob together
oh what club yeah yeah yeah Club bed
great the board game club I love it well
thank you so much congratulations again
on season three thank you for your time